osman cábala es una figura clave en el
mundo de la cultura y el arte en turquía
desde los años 80 fundado y financiado
varias estructuras que han permitido el
debate público sobre los temas más
delicados el tema kurdo la ecología los
derechos de los lg piti o el genocidio
armenio como en esta exposición de 2011
en su centro de arte de estambul un
museo instalado en un antiguo almacén de
su familia que y su fortuna con el
tabaco
creemos que es muy importante que
nuestros visitantes y la población turca
en general tengan acceso directo a la
obra de un artista armenio
para que haya algún tipo de comunicación
algún tipo de diálogo
vagabov
las ideas del multimillonario no gustan
nada a la turquía ultra conservadora de
recep tayyip erdogán
encarcelado por su presunta implicación
en la revuelta popular de 2013 fue
finalmente absuelto en 2020 por falta de
pruebas
pero a las pocas horas de su absolución
vuelve a ser encarcelado acusado
nuevamente de desestabilizar turquía
esta vez en el fallido golpe de estado
de 2016 desde entonces osman cábala
permanece en la prisión de alta
seguridad de silivri en la periferia de
estambul aunque los cargos que se me
imputan no se basan en ninguna prueba
llevo cuatro años detenidos los
comentarios abusivos y difamatorios del
precedente contra una persona que no ha
sido condenada y cuyo juicio está en
curso suponen un ataque a la dignidad
humana ya en 2019 el tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos ordenó la liberación
inmediata de osman cabal a una petición
que nunca ha sido atendida a principios
de octubre a un tribunal de estambul
dictaminó que permanecería en prisión
hasta al menos el 26 de noviembre a
pesar de las amenazas de sanciones
europeas contra